[Aplausos]
me creí atlético todos tenemos algo
común soñar pero más importante al
cumplir tus sueños todo lo que fue
esos sueños por cumplir
se lo dijimos nos lanzamos pero siempre
[Música]
esto pasa por varios cultivos que le
presentaron
por esto
[Música]
lo que pasa es que hicimos
estudiantes gracias a aquellas personas
que hacen públicos sus sueños es menos
probable que en términos de llevarlos a
cabo
otra cosa
[Música]
es un camino sí pero qué más
si me motiva
felicita a los vídeos
no va a estar
infórmate e investiga a números
sentimientos
y hemos de trabajar
están listos y encantar
pero necesitamos aprender para poner
fecha de inicio que cristina a nuestros
sueños
y para cuándo
comienzo a córner y esto lo coloca en
una base ideal sería que el 10%
haciendo me parece como dónde cómo
cuándo y por qué
y
[Música]
por ejemplo
y para mí el 10 por ciento
como cada 15 días porque contigo mismo
todos comenzamos
ya llevaba de 50 por ciento
después comencé
por último les voy a decir gracias a mi
mamá sola
[Música]
tengo unos 200
buscan estas listas imágenes enteros y
primeras recortadas y pegadas
bonito y el mercado que tenga su
habitación
es fácil
adriano todos los puntos importantes y
relaciones son tus sueños esto te
permitirá enfocarse en el objetivo
[Música]
y después
después la vida cambia después después
[Música]
puedes hacer
d
[Aplausos]